okay today I'm going to talk to you
about current and circuits to help
illustrate this I've just got a real
simple circuit here that's made of a
cell that's what provides the push or
potential difference in the circuit an
ammeter that's what measures the current
a filament lamp and a switch so whenever
we think of current the first thing we
think of is a flow of charge just like
for example in a river the current would
be the flow of water in a circuit it's
the flow of charge and in particular in
a circuit with metal wire the thing that
is flowing around the circuit is
electrons or rather our electrons so to
understand more about this we need to
know a little bit more about the
structure of a wire so why is normally
have a plastic coating because plastic
is an insulator and doesn't allow the
electricity to flow out inside that
plastic coating we have a metal often
copper now that metal is what contains
the electrons which flow around the
circuit underneath I've done a diagram
to show metallic bonding in metallic
bonding we have lots of positive metal
ions and all around the ions we have
these little delocalized electrons what
that means is when the circuit is
provided with the potential difference a
kind of push these electrons are free to
flow around the circuit they flow around
the circuit now the mistake that lots of
people normally make is they think all
the electrons start here in the cell and
then they leave the cell and flow around
the circuit that isn't true just like
we've seen from this diagram of metallic
bonding all of the electrons start
within the copper itself so in this wire
all the way around there are electrons
ready to flow around the circuit so why
if i put flow of charge rather than flow
of electrons now the reason for that is
quite simple charge is measured in
coulombs
and the unit for that is just the
capital C now what a Coulomb is is lots
and lots of electrons so but in order to
kind of try and measure the flow of
charge around the circuit we need to be
able to count how many electrons are
flowing by at any any time now the
reason why that's extremely difficult is
there are so many electrons that will
flow around electrons are absolutely
tiny and so literally billions of them
will flow past the point in let's say a
second so that's why instead we use one
Coulomb six point two eight times ten to
the 18 electrons that many electrons is
one Coulomb so that's why we use
coulombs rather than electrons so what
is the current now this component here
is called an ammeter this is what
measures or counts how much charge is
passing a point in a certain period of
time and we actually have this nice
equation triangle but I'd like to try to
explain to you right now so Q stands for
charge i stands for current and T stands
for time so Q is charge measured in
coulombs I is current measured in amps
and finally T is time measured in
seconds so let's just have a quick think
about this ammeter here let's imagine
one Coulomb of charge so IE that many
electrons let's imagine one Coulomb of
charge passes through this ammeter or
flows through this ammeter in one second
so my current is going to equal to find
this out ID Q divided by T is Q divided
by T so in this case let's imagine one
Coulomb passes through that ammeter in
one
second 1/1 is one amp so that's what the
current is current is measuring the flow
of charge around the circuit so if one
Coulomb goes past this point in one
second I'm gonna have one amp
now let's imagine this time let's say
I've increased my potential difference
so what will happen is this time I've
got a bigger push of electrons around
the circuit they're going to flow
through and faster rate so this time
let's imagine rather than one Coulomb
passing this point in one second we have
two coulombs passing through this
ammeter in one second so this time my
current is going to equal two coulombs
passing through in one second so two
divided by one is two amps so can we see
the more coulombs that flow through the
point per second means a bigger current
so that's basically what current is
remember it's the flow of charge that is
what a Coulomb is that many electrons
and what an ammeter does it reads the
current so reads how much charge flows
bus here every single second thank you